auch mich hat etwas bewegt es ist die
korona pandemie diesen wochen bewegt
aber diesmal ist es eine sache im
bundestag und zwar wurde ja für mich
ehrlich gesagt jetzt bürgerinnen einfach
mal so der genesenen status für uns
bürger von sechs monaten auf drei monate
herabgesetzt
im bundestag darf man jetzt aber auch
weiterhin teilnehmen denn dort geht es
noch bis sechs monate da frag ich mich
okay was ist da eigentlich los geht
gelten für politiker andere regeln als
für die bürger für mich hat es etwas von
beim predigen und wasser trinken
also das kann ich nur bestätigen aber
gerade was die gerechtigkeit in dem fall
angeht gibt es doch sehr viel lobbyismus
also warum dürfen kinder nicht in die
schule gehen aber fußballspiele sind
alle haupt- und
das ist eine von vielen dingen die jetzt
wieder passiert sind wo man eben sagt
naja vielleicht fällt ja niemanden auf
aber als journalist sitzt man natürlich
dichter dran und kriegt einige sachen
ganz anders mit und ich finde es gut das
ist hier mal zur sprache kommt ja selbst
betroffen bin frau schenk ist es eine
sache die gar nicht geht das ist genau
die politikverdrossenheit die alle mit
mängeln ich meine man muss sagen es wird
ja eigentlich alles reguliert und sehr
schnell im bundestag wir müssen selbst
im café aufschreiben wenn sie selbst auf
toilette gehen in den deutschen
bundestag steht da ein schild jetzt zu
corona der aufenthalt muss kurz sein ja
und das ist wird alles schnell reguliert
also wenn der toilettengang schnell
reguliert hielt dann sollte man auch
dieses schnell regulieren ich finde das
muss man von jedem erwarten können
deswegen haben wir auch heute
interveniert das möglichst schnell hier
wirklich gleiche regeln für gleiche
gelten ich bin genauso ein bürger wie
der bürger auf der straße und das muss
auch geld wie kann das denn eigentlich
passieren also wie kommt so etwas
zustande dass nicht nur das lka heute
hat die polter den genesenen status
einfach einfach mal halbiert über nacht
und wie kann so etwas passieren dass das
durch den bundestag geht macht das die
bundestagspräsidentin im alleingang oder
ist der ältestenrat involviert und hat
beide augen zugedrückt wie passiert so
was das ist der verwaltungsapparat das
ist nicht flexibel ich will nicht sagen
ich lösche das sofort nur wenn ich diese
mails bekommen neue regeln im bundestag
das ist ohne lange latte dann ist da ein
grosser anderen habe ich schon keinen
bock mehr darauf und das zeigt die die
die völlige fehlende flexibilisierung
flexibilität im verwaltungsapparat das
geht runter bis zur kommune der stark
muss eigentlich dienstleister seien für
die bürger und nicht staat in dem sinne
wir sind der staat und ihr seid da unten
wir haben auf jeden fall bald ein echtes
akzeptanzproblem nicht nur in der
pandemie bewältigung passieren fehler
sondern eben auch in der frage was gilt
für uns und was gilt für andere ist es
ist für mich ein rätsel ich glaube
bärbel bas wird das sehr schnell
passieren wir sind die nächsten tage
schon egal ob die union da jetzt
interveniert hat oder oder nicht die
bürger sind ja immer noch gefrustet dass
sie plötzlich nicht mehr vollständig
geimpft sind obwohl sie zwei mal geimpft
sind manche warten auf den booster
termin weil sie noch nicht haben dürfen
und wir sind nicht gelten dann wird sich
nicht mehr als geimpfte es ist wahnsinn
was an irrungen und wirrungen gerade in
der korona politik los sind und diese
einzig wichtige politische kriterien was
man eigentlich immer hat
nachvollziehbarkeit von maßnahmen wird
gerade eigentlich durch die decke
geschossen also es ist traurig aber da
würde mich natürlich auch interessieren
denn im gemeistert werden muss weil die
impfung nicht mehr so lange vorhält wie
ist es denn dann mit den genießenden
hält es wirklich nicht so lange vor es
ist deswegen sinnvoll die zeit zu
verkürzen
und wie sieht es dann aber auch wirklich
die nachfolge man bucht sein urlaub man
man muss arbeiten gehen wie sieht es aus
mit den arbeitgebern wie sind was hat es
alles für folgen für die bevölkerung und
das muss man natürlich abwägen und über
die frage stelle ich mir natürlich auch
es gibt die stadt in süddeutschland der
ist konstanz und ist direkt an der
schweizer grenze danach gibt es eine
stadt die eis kreuzlingen es sind 500
meter dann sind sie in beiden städten in
der einen stadt ist der genesenden
status zwölf monate und in der anderen
stadt drei monaten ich bin leider aber
irgendwie kann man von der wissenschaft
die frage stellen wie man auf so etwas
kommt ich glaube wir werden druck aber
haben sie sich auch herr lindemann und
frau gilt sie ja auch sind ja auch ein
politischer mensch der termin ist auch
jetzt echt an ämtern geschnuppert hat
das eigentlich es so etwas gibt wie den
hang der volksvertreter gerne bis ins
kleinste detail dinge zu regeln für den
bürger also sich auch seine legitimation
da rauszuholen so dass man als dieses
mikromanagement eigentlich beschreiben
das was da passiert dass man versucht
sogar und das haben wir alles erlebt die
anzahl von kindern die zu einem
kindergeburtstag kommen dürfen dann
festzulegen also in drin nur noch acht
oder nur noch zehn das gab es letztes
jahr alles diese regelung also wie
kommen volksvertreter und dann können
sie vielleicht weil er auch was zu sagen
auf die idee dinge wirklich bis ins menü
nachher noch die schuhe größte was
journalisten an schulen tragen dürfen zu
regeln oder kommt dann weil man angst
hat risiko zu gehen und dann regelt man
alles im detail damit man bloß nicht
schuldig ist im nachhinein es hat keiner
mehr den mut zu sagen das ist jetzt der
weg das ist jetzt die richtung und wir
machen das jetzt so und ich nehme auch
die verantwortung dafür das ist leider
deutschland der wohlstand hat und satt
gemacht ich glaube medizinisch gibt es
ja durchaus gute gründe denn wenn karl
lauterbach und so verstehe ich ihnen
sagt ja was auf wenn der schutz den
impfschutz nach 23 monaten auf null
sinkt auf 10 prozent sondern musst du
die politik verändern das problem ist
die kommunikation ja da kommt ein lkw
gutachten über nacht in den bundesrat
hinein die länderchefs wissen gar nicht
bescheid die müssen das aber auch noch
mit muslimen geschrieben bescheid wie
auch im bundestag ja ich auch nicht mehr
so was kann noch nicht passiert wenn
selbst die länderchefs die das umsetzen
müssen nicht bescheid wissen was das lka
macht frage ich mich wie kann karl
lauterbach diese behörde und den ideen
der schüler haben ja so ist es zumindest
unser wissensstand die länderchefs haben
ja die zusage von karl lauterbach
bekommen dass er sie ja wohl dauert es
noch investieren also stimmt jetzt mal
mit ja und dann könnt ihr aber noch ein
bisschen noch daran rumschrauben und
noch mal sagen was euch eigentlich
bedrückt bei der ganzen geschichte und
wahrheit extrem empörten überrascht dass
wenige stunden später diese ganze
genesungs verkürzung oder halbierung
muss man sagen dann schon quasi ja
verorteten status hatte er hat ryanair
kann man als staat machen aber nicht als
politiker oder politiker der pandemie
das ist echt das problem und wenn wir
nicht bald auf dieser pandemie irgendwie
raus kommen wird dieser schaden in denen
diese politikverdrossen wird aufgrund
dieser aktuellen politik natürlich mit
sich bringt da wird immens sein und
damit langfristig seien insofern ist es
für sie herr lehmann und egal welche
partei am ende ein ernsthaftes problem
ja es ist einfach so dass man zwar den
den menschen sagen wir ja wir sind
liberal zum beispiel wir fdp und die die
menschen sollen selber entscheiden aber
letztendlich ist doch die gesundheit und
das leben und die sicherheit der
menschen dann doch wichtiger und dann
muss man auch wenn es ein nicht gefällt
dann manchmal doch sagen okay wir machen
das jetzt so die anschnallpflicht und
rauchverbot und es gibt ja einiges wo
die menschen zu etwas gezwungen wurden
aber trotzdem sollte man die bürger mit
einbeziehen und sie richtig informieren
und ich habe ganz auf den eindruck dass
die politiker sich wie schafhirten
fühlen die alles nur gute wollen für
ihre scharfe und die auch meinen sich in
allem wunderbar und am besten
ausgegangen aber die menschen sind nun
mal keine jobs so ein bisschen ahnung
von volksvertretern zu volks bestimmen
oder in der nahrung und das ist richtig
wenn man sich an denen er kona gipfel
von gestern noch mal so ein bisschen
zurück erinnert ich weiß nicht inwieweit
michael brücker sicherlich in jena steht
ja auch die beide wahrscheinlich auch
dieses papier die siebenseitige das
beschlusspapier nachher durchgelesen hat
was für banalitäten muss man sagen in
diesem papier standen erschreckende
banalitäten also dann hätte man sich
auch gar nicht treffen müssen wir daran
steht wir wollen über eine öffnung
perspektive beraten wenn es dann so weit
ist oder ein gesundheitsminister wird
aufgefordert dafür zu sorgen bei einem
pcr-test mangel diesen mangel zu beheben
ist
das projekt also einer hat da regiert
eher mittelmäßig und die sache jetzt ihr
oder gucke ich sie an das ist gar nicht
fair aber sie als stellvertreter
sozusagen von vielen anderen auch der
mikro macht ihr haargenau schreibt ihr
einsatz vor was passiert und wenn es
dann dazu kommt beispielsweise mal
zusammen wie geht es eigentlich jetzt
weiter wer kann als erstes öffnen sagt
majors entscheiden wir wenn es soweit
ist muss man hier nicht sagen die frage
richtig auch sehr gerne ein herr lehmann
ich habe letztens aus fdp kreisen gehört
ohne uns hätte es die lok sonst wieder
gegeben weil die cdu wenn sie an die
macht gekommen wäre sowieso geschlossen
dementsprechend hätte man wäre es denn
mit ihnen jetzt weiter gewesen
weitergelaufen jetzt sage ich natürlich
es hätte keine chance gegeben das ist
dieses hin- und hergeschiebe das waren
die leute dann immer höheren glaube
entscheidend ist was er schäfer sagt
warum steht dass da alles so
verklausuliert und so weiter weil sich
jeder versteckt hinter paragrafen wir
brauchen eigentlich mal wieder mutbürger
es gab für mich zwei drei mut bürger in
dieser pandemie der eine war zum
beispiel der bürgermeister madsen
ausrüstungen alle haben gesagt im lok
dar und wir machen nichts er wurde
angerufen von einzelhändlern und dann
hat er dieses click and meet erfunden
weil bürger gesagt lass mich doch da
anrufen dann hole ich die schuhe ab oder
die tasche oder die flasche wein und
dann machen wir das so und halten
zumindest den einzelhandel so ein
bisschen noch am leben alle haben sich
versteckt dann lief es hat ganz
deutschland nach gemacht das wäre mein
vorschlag 30 modellregionen in
deutschland für mutbürger diejenigen die
das ausprobieren wollen dürfen das
machen und wenn es läuft jetzt
ausgerollt in ganz deutschland das wäre
eine tolle sache gewesen aber wir hatten
natürlich auch ein bisschen pech dass
gerade als die panini losging war mitten
im wahlkampf und keiner wollte den
fehler machen sondern wollte gewählt
werden und dann ja dann war zwar gewählt
aber in der übergangsphase wo alle mit
koalitionsgesprächen beschäftigt waren
aber die cdu immer noch an der macht da
wollte dann auch keiner was tun und auch
die cdu hat sich da zurück gehalten und
das waren aber entscheidende phasen
gewesen wo man vielleicht etwas hätte
beschließen und machen sollen ein mut
bürgermeister will ich noch erwähnen den
aus bremen ich finde nämlich der hat
damals die impfzentren nicht geschlossen
als wir sagen wir mal im spätsommer der
meinung waren wir brauchen den ich mir
auch ein politiker der union auch der
gesundheitsminister hier einsparen und
er hat gesagt ich muss die impfzentren
haben weil wir brauchen
niedrigschwellige angebote für impfungen
in den vierteln wo manche menschen nicht
mal mehr ein hausarzt haben da müssen
wir rein da sind heute übrigens jetzt
auch die probleme da haben wir die
impflücken da hat er sie offen gehalten
deswegen die impf wurde da heute auch so
hoch wie sie ist also es gibt auch gute
beispiele da bin ich ganz klar mehr mut
bürgermeister ich finde das ist eine
ganz tolle forderung oder eine schnelle
je zur beendigung eines themas